let's talk about the thing that got us
all the most excited I feel that I
there's no reservation and saying this
was like my most thrilling moment III
thus far the hololens demo of Minecraft
Oh Milo wow that you read of what I mean
so we were talking before the show about
how hololens sort of has the advantage
on VR because you can rig up a special
camera and then see it in action and
that this table we see here is where he
sort of transfers the game to and we're
seeing it in action and I still didn't
want to believe it I want ya threw out
like what is the trick here yeah how are
they faking this but Justin hey Walt our
senior news producer here was saying yes
is negated yeah that's what it looks
like it is incredibly immersive yet and
I mean is this is this basically what
you like what you even even though
Justin has said it looks sure I still
can't believe it like it's it it looks
incredible like the way he's just moving
into the actual like the the composition
of the image and just looking around it
looks it looks insane I don't know how
they're doing it which is kind of the
best thing you can say about it just
feels like magic and is actually right i
mean if it's anything like this i'm
gonna have together yeah it's just like
and the best thing is like like we were
saying earlier it's it's just completely
different from normal vr yeah it's just
so different oh my God look at how my
god I've not played much minecraft but
man I am looking forward to pounce on a
whim oh crap i'm like like i want to
play them down with us on minecraft open
my fingers around doing this stuff yeah
and it's just I mean Mike could they
pick a debt a better game to demo
exactly minecraft is just sort the
spirit of Play and exploration and it's
laid out there right in front of you and
that's really what you want when I think
when you have a new piece of gear like
hololens you want it to be something
that people are excited to play to
explore in and to just kind of mess
around with and this kind of sandbox
experience of Minecraft the way that
they've kept the sort of calibrated it
it just I'm just thinking about it all
the stories how much positive praise and
press they got in the early days of
Minecraft for being like a really
interesting and intuitive tool for kids
to learn things like engineering and
back
jokingly all elevators and that kind of
stuff and then seeing this and just
thinking man they've just taken that to
a whole new level they could have this
like in our classrooms and that kind of
thing is a learning thing that's the
exciting thing this was just one
demonstration of what you could create
yeah like with this tool but like people
are gonna create these incredible Creek
these weird idiosyncratic yeah creation
I mean you'd easily give this to like
surgeons and get them to do like trial
runs on surgeries and that kind of thing
like the applications of it now I just
mind-blowing it's obviously we're just
gonna play minecraft with it because
we're not that smart it's really I mean
it's like because this is so believably
awesome it really I'm thinking as you
guys are describing other applications
of the trailer they show yeah and it's
like I'm building them I'm designing a
motorcycle I'm doing a powerpoint
presentation I'm doing all this stuff
like it makes me a believer that that
stuff could work yeah and you yeah work
well because this works so well I want
it to work as well yeah oh my goodness
yeah whatever they want to believe i
believe in hololens fascinating look at
microsoft's hololens playing minecraft
at microsoft's press conference here at
e3 2015